>>> WELCOME TO "THE LEAD."
I'M JAKE TAPPER.
A DESPERATE SITUATION AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER GROWING EVEN
MORE DIRE TODAY.
RIGHT NOW THOUSANDS OF HAITIAN
MIGRANTS ARE LEFT IN LIMBO BOTH
IN TEXAS AND IN MEXICO.
AS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
STRUGGLES TO GET A HAND ON THE
CRISIS, MIGRANTS WEIGHED ACROSS
THE RIO GRANDE WITH MINIMAL
BELONGINGS PILED ON THEIR HEADS
HOPING FOR A BETTER LIFE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AT ONE POINT TODAY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN MEXICO FORMING A
HUMAN CHAIN OF SORTS TRYING TO
STOP MIGRANTS FROM MAKING THE
TRIP ACROSS THE RIVER.
NOT ALL THE MIGRANTS WHO MAKE
THE TREK WILL BE ALLOWED TO
REMAIN IN THE U.S.
MORE THAN A THOUSAND HAITIANS
HAVE BEEN DEPORTED FROM THE
U.S./MEXICO BORDER.
3600 REMAIN UNDER THE DEL RIO
INTERNATIONAL BRIDGE IN TEXAS.
WE'RE COVERING THE CRISIS FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE RIO GRANDE.
CNN'S ROSA FLORES IS IN DEL RIO,
TEXAS.
I'LL START WITH CNN'S MATT
RIVERS IN ACUNA, MEXICO.
YOU JUST SAW A GREAT NUMBER OF
HAITIANS MAKING THEIR WAY TO THE
U.S.
TELL US MORE.
>> Reporter: BASICALLY, JAKE, IN
THE LAST TWO HOURS OR SO THINGS
HAVE REALLY CHANGED HERE ON THE
MEXICO SIDE.
WHEN WE SPOKE TO YOU YESTERDAY,
YOU SAW THERE WAS LOTS OF PEOPLE
GOING BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
HERE ON THE MEXICO SIDE AND THE
U.S. SIDE.
THERE WAS EVEN A ROPE STRUNG
BETWEEN BOTH SIDES WITH PEOPLE
COMING FROM THE U.S., HERE TO
MEXICO, ACTUALLY BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO GET SUPPLIES, FOOD,
WATER, THINGS LIKE THAT.
EASIER TO GET THAN ON THE U.S.
SIDE.
I CAN SHOW YOU THE SCENE NOW IF
WE SHOW YOU THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE RIVER THERE YOU CAN SEE SOME
HAITIAN MIGRANTS THAT JUST MADE
IT ACROSS AND THERE ARE SOME
BORDER PATROL PEOPLE STILL
ALLOWING THOSE PEOPLE TO CROSS
BUT THERE'S A LOT LESS HAITIAN
MIGRANTS COMING HERE NOW.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE OF A
STEPPED UP MEXICAN ENFORCEMENT.
SO IF I TURN AROUND HERE, THESE
TRUCKS HERE WERE NOT HERE
BEFORE.
THE SOLDIERS WERE NOT HERE
IF YOU TURN HERE YOU CAN SEE
THESE GUYS.
THEY JUST SHOWED UP HERE VERY
RECENTLY.
AND WHAT ENDED UP HAPPENING,
JAKE, WAS AT FIRST THERE WAS SIX
OR SEVEN PEOPLE THAT SHOWED UP
HERE, JUST IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS
STANDING LIKE THIS CLEARLY
TRYING TO PREVENT SOME HAITIANS
FROM GOING ACROSS.
WHAT HAPPENED IS WORD SPREAD
VERY QUICKLY THROUGH THE CAMP
THAT SOMETHING WAS HAPPENING
HERE THAT HADN'T HAPPENED
BEFORE.
AS A RESULT, SEVERAL DOZEN
MIGRANTS MADE THEIR WAY HERE
VERY QUICKLY AND KIND OF RUSHED
THE OFFICERS AND THE OFFICERS
REALLY COULDN'T STOP THEM.
THERE WAS A MAD DASH ACROSS THE
BORDER.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN COMING TO
MEXICO MAYBE TO STAY FOR A
NIGHT, GET A HOT MEAL, ESCAPE
THE MADNESS ESSENTIALLY
HAPPENING ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE BORDER.
WHEN THEY FOUND OUT THEY WERE
STUCK HERE IN MEXICO OR MIGHT BE
STUCK, MANY TRIED TO BE SURE
THEY COULD BACK TO THE U.S.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GO THROUGH
THE IMMIGRATION PROCESS OVER
THERE.
AS A RESULT IT WAS A RUSH TOWARD
THE BORDER.
CLEARLY THE IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS IN MEXICO WERE
OVERWHELMED AT FIRST.
THE INITIAL WAVE WENT.
REINFORCEMENTS HAVE COME.
THESE GUYS MUCH MORE HEAVILY
OUTFITTED THAN THE FIRST PEOPLE
HERE THAT CAME.
AS OF NOW, JAKE, SAFE TO SAY AT
LEAST IN THIS SECTION THERE ARE
NO MORE MIGRANTS ALLOWED TO
CROSS FROM MEXICO TO THE U.S.
AND VICE VERSA.
IF YOU ARE A HAITIAN MIGRANT AND
IN MEXICO AT THIS POINT YOU'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH EITHER THE
IMMIGRATION PROCESS OR THE
DEPORTATION PROCESS FROM THIS
SIDE OF THE BORDER.
>> YOU JUST SAW SOME BOAT
PATROLS ARRIVING.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
WE HAVE SEEN ALSO A STEPPED UP
PRESENCE FROM THE U.S. SIDE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS WE SAW U.S. BORDER
PATROL, PATROLLING ON BOATS ON
THAT SIDE OF THE RIVER.
AS OF THIS POINT STILL EVERY NOW
AND THEN A HAITIAN MIGRANT PLAN
AJS TO MAKE THEIR WAY ACROSS AND
BORDER PATROL IS ALLOWING THOSE
PEOPLE TO GO TO THAT ENCAMPMENT
UNDER THE INTERNATIONAL BRIDGE
IN DEL RIO.
THEY ARE STILL LETTING PEOPLE
ON, NOT FORCING THEM BACK TO
MEXICO, BUT THERE IS STEPPED UP
ACTIVITY ON THAT SIDE OF THE
BORDER AS WELL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MATT RIVERS, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S HOP ACROSS THE RIO GRANDE
NOW.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY IS TEMPORARILY STOPPING
THE USE OF HORSE PATROLS IN THE
DEL RIO, TEXAS SECTOR AFTER DAYS
OF OUTRAGE FROM BOTH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS AFTER THESE IMAGES
SPREAD OF BORDER PATROL AGENTS
ON HORSEBACK AGGRESSIVELY
CONFRONTING HAITIAN MIGRANTS.
AS CNN'S ROSA FLORES REPORTS FOR
US NOW THE INVESTIGATION INTO
THE INCIDENT IS ONGOING.
>> Reporter: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION STRATEGY ON THE
DEL RIO MIGRANT CRISIS DRAWING
CRITICISM.
AS TO WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
SAYS --
>> IN ORDER TO ENSURE MIGRANTS
ARE SWIFTLY TAKEN INTO CUSTODY,
PROCESSED, AND REMOVED FROM THE
UNITED STATES CONSISTENT WITH
OUR LAWS AND POLICIES.
>> Reporter: DOZENS TELL THE
WHOLE STORY ON THE GROUND.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SAYS ABOUT 1400
HAITIANS HAVE BEEN SENT BACK TO
HAITI SINCE SEPTEMBER 19th.
THE MOVE CREATING CHAOS ON THE
TARMAC IN PORT-au-PRINCE.
THE U.S.'S SPECIAL ENVOY TO
HAITI SUBMITTED HIS RESIGNATION
CITING THE INHUMANE DECISION TO
DEPORT THOUSANDS OF HAITIAN
REFUGEES CALLING U.S. POLICY
DEEPLY FLAWED.
THIS AFTER BORDER PATROL AGENTS
ON HORSEBACK USED AGGRESSIVE
TACTICS AGAINST MIGRANTS.
DHS NOW ANNOUNCING TEMPORARY
SUSPENSION OF HORSE PATROL IN
DEL RIO.
3200 MIGRANTS WERE TRANSPORTED
OUT OF DEL RIO AND ARE IN
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION.
CUSTODY DHS SAYS.
SINCE MONDAY MORE THAN 1300
MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN RELEASED BY
BORDER PATROL IN DEL RIO ALONE
ACCORDING TO A LOCAL NONPROFIT.
>> SIX DAYS UNDER THE BRIDGE.
THAT IS WHERE WE MET A HAITIAN
WOMAN WHO SAID THAT MIGRANTS ARE
GIVEN A NUMBER ON A TICKET UNDER
THE BRIDGE.
SHE HAD A YELLOW TICKET.
DID THEY TELL YOU WHY IT WAS
YELLOW?
WHEN HER NUMBER WAS CALLED SHE
SAYS SHE WAS PROCESSED AND
ALLOWED TO STAY IN THE UNITED
STATES.
SHE IS THANKFUL SHE IS ALLOWED
TO STAY SHE SAYS BECAUSE IN
HAITI SHE WOULDN'T HAVE A PLACE
TO LIVE.
BUT CNN HAS LEARNED UP TO 30,000
HAITIANS IN COLOMBIA COULD BE
HEADING TO THE U.S. SOUTHERN
BORDER.
CNN CAMERAS CAPTURING MIGRANTS
FLOWING INTO TEXAS NEAR THE DEL
RIO INTERNATIONAL BRIDGE.
FROM THE AIR, THE CAMP CLEARLY
SHRINKING.
FROM THE GROUND -- YOU'LL SEE
BEHIND ME THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRESENCE IS STILL VERY HEAVY.
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK UNDER THE
BRIDGE AND YOU'LL SEE THE NUMBER
OF MIGRANTS HAS DWINDLED BUT IF
YOU LOOK AROUND YOU'LL SEE THE
NUMBER OF RESOURCES HAS
INCREASED.
CNN GETTING AN EXCLUSIVE LOOK
INSIDE A FIELD HOSPITAL THAT
JUST WENT UP.
THIS IS THE EMERGENCY CARE
CENTER.
THE CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER SAYS
70 PATIENTS WERE TREATED IN THE
FIRST 24 HOURS.
>> ENVIRONMENTAL INJURIES, SOME
HEAT INJURIES, SOME OCCASIONAL
NAUSEA, DIARRHEA.
SOME RESPIRATORY ILLNESS.
FROM THE DUST AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
>> Reporter: MONTHS BEFORE THIS
CAMP WENT UP THE LOCAL BORDER
PATROL UNION SAYS AGENTS ASKED
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES BECAUSE OF
AN INCREASE IN BORDER CROSSINGS.
BUT THE RESOURCES DIDN'T ARRIVE
UNTIL RECENT DAYS.
NOW TO A DRAMATIC CHANGE HERE IN
DEL RIO.
I WANT TO GO STRAIGHT TO LIVE
DRONE IMAGES BECAUSE THE CAMP
THAT WAS RIGHT NEXT TO THE
BRIDGE YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK AT IT
YOURSELF.
IT IS GETTING BULLDOZED.
THIS IS IN LINE WITH WHAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM OFFICIALS THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE DWINDLING.
AT LAST CHECK ABOUT 3600.
NOW, THIS AS THE U.N. REFUGEE
CHIEF SAYS THE CONDITIONS UNDER
THIS BRIDGE ARE DEPLORABLE AND
THAT MASS EXPULSIONS OF PEOPLE
TO HAITI IF NOT PROPERLY
PROCESSED IS JUST NOT CONSISTENT
WITH INTERNATIONAL NORMS.
JAKE?
>> ALL RIGHT.
ROSA FLORES IN DEL RIO, TEXAS.
WE'VE GONE TO TEXAS AND TO
MEXICO.
COMING UP WE'LL TAKE YOU TO
HAITI.
IN THE MEANTIME LET'S DISCUSS
THIS WITH DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN FREDRICKA WILSON
OF FLORIDA WHO REPRESENTS
MIAMI'S LITTLE HAITI
NEIGHBORHOOD.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
TODAY THE U.S. SPECIAL ENVOY TO
HAITI QUIT OVER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S HANDLING OF
THIS INFLUX OF HAITIAN MIGRANTS.
HE CALLED THE BIDEN APPROACH,
QUOTE, INHUMANE,
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE, AND DEEPLY
FLAWED, UNQUOTE.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> HE WAS SUCH A GREAT ENVOY,
AND I AM SO DISAPPOINTED THAT HE
LEFT.
WE BEGGED HIM NOT TO LEAVE, TO
TRY TO WORK THROUGH ALL OF THE
DIFFICULTY.
BUT WE COULD NOT CONVINCE HIM.
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES AND THERE
ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT I FEEL
SO DISAPPOINTED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT.
IN FACT I AM PISSED.
THAT IS THE WO